good afternoon I've just been to see her
Majesty the Queen earlier on and she
agreed to dissolve Parliament for an
election I want you to know of course
that I don't want an early election and
no one much wants to have an election in
December but we've got to the stage
where we have no choice because our
Parliament is paralyzed it's been stuck
in a rut for three and a half years and
I'm afraid our MPs are just refusing
time and again to deliver brexit and
honor the mandate of the people I can
tell you I've got to the stage rather
you wanting to chew my own tie in
frustration because in a sense we're so
nearly there we've got a deal
oven ready by which we can leave the EU
in just a few weeks it's a great deal
for this country it delivers everything
that I wanted when I campaigned for
brexit we cannot only take back control
of our money and yes we'll be able to
spend hundreds of millions every week on
our priorities such as the NHS when you
take back control of our borders with an
Australian style points based system so
that we can attract the workers from
scientists agricultural workers that our
economy actually needs and we can take
that control of our laws so that we can
do things differently and better if we
choose from free ports to free trade
deals from banning the cruel live
shipment of animals to cutting v8e
on sanitary products and we can leave
the EU as one UK whole and entire and
perfect as we promised and so it's been
frankly mind-boggling in the last few
weeks to see how Parliament first first
voted to approve this deal and then
voted for delay and I'm afraid that it
is clear that if Parliament had its way
then this country would not be leaving
even on January the 31st and that of
course is bad for democracy it's
disastrous for trust in politics
why should mp's decide that they can
cancel the result of a referendum
I'm afraid I also think that this delay
is now bad for the country and for the
economy and with every week that goes by
uncertainty is deterring people from
hiring new staff from buying new homes
from making new investments and if we
can get this deal over the line with a
sensible majority government we
certainly can then we can release that
pent up flood of investment hundreds of
billions are waiting to pour into the UK
and we can inject a surge of confidence
into our system and we in this
government can get on with delivering on
the priorities of the people I'm very
proud of what we've done in the last 108
days or whatever it is 108 days or so
the biggest program of NHS investment
for a generation lifting up funding of
schools across the country 40 new
hospitals by the way lifting up funding
of schools across the country putting
20,000 more police on the streets an
infrastructure revolution were planning
in rail in route and Road from electric
buses to new green cycle schemes gigabit
broadband in every home and we have the
confidence as one nation conservatives
to make those investments not despite
our belief in a strong private sector
but precisely because we champion this
enterprise economy in the UK and when
people get up at 5:00 a.m. to get their
businesses ready when they risk their
own money or mortgage their own homes to
develop a new product or a new venture
when they have the guts to find a new
market at home or abroad we don't sneer
at them we cheer for them and do what we
can to help because we understand that
it's only by having a dynamic free
market economy that we can deliver on
our program of uniting this country and
levelling up with infrastructure
education and technology and it's only
if you have great public services that
you can have a successful market economy
so I say come with us
that's the choice of this election that
the choice come with us a government
that's putting billions into education
all go with Jeremy and here now
I'm coming the alternative who actually
want to ban Ofsted that protects kids
from bullying in the classroom come with
us a government the believes in high
wages is raising the living wage to 10
pounds 50 the biggest ever increase or
go with a left-wing Labour Party that
believes in high taxes for everyone and
that voted under this government for
seven against seven thousand eight
hundred pounds of tax cuts on working
people that's what they did come with us
put in a points-based immigration system
or go with labour and a totally
uncontrolled an unlimited immigration
system that would put huge pressure on
the NHS and other services come with us
a government that believes Britain
should stand tall in the world or go
with Jeremy Corbyn and the Labour Party
who sided with Putin when Russia
ordered poisonings on the streets of
Salisbury come with us get brexit done
and take this country forward oh and
this is the alternative next year spend
the whole of 2020 in a horror show of
yet more differe underlay imagine waking
up on Friday the December the 13th and
finding Corbin at the head of his
Technicolor yawn of a coalition they
would spend the whole of 2020 having to
two referendums one on Scotland because
he's done a deal with the Scots
nationalists to assist the breakup of
the Union if they sustained him in power
and another another referendum on brexit
which is meant to happen in nine months
time after he's renegotiated supposedly
our exit and renegotiated this deal and
what is his plan for that renegotiation
what question would be put to the public
we don't know what are the options we
don't know we don't even know what side
he would take and we don't know what
would happen if the result was either
four remain or four leave
best of three call it quits we don't
know what we do know is that in any
scenario that vivir and the drift and
the delay which is increasingly damaging
for our country would just continue and
we do know that there's only one way to
avoid that nightmare and that is to vote
for a moderate and compassionate one
nation conservative government and we
will make this country the greatest
place to live
to raise a family to start up a business
to send your kids to school a country
where we lead the world in cutting co2
and tackling climate change in clean
green technology where we stand up for
our values around the world a country
where everybody has the opportunity to
make the most of their lives and where
we work as a government to give them
that opportunity from the moment they
are born and that is our mission if I
come back here with a working majority
in parliament then I will get Parliament
working again for you on day one of the
new Parliament in December we will start
getting our deal through so we can get
brexit done in January and unleash this
country's potential will put uncertainty
behind us families and businesses will
be able to plan
let's make 2020 the year of investment
and growth not the year of two
referendums I want to thank everyone in
the building behind me and across
government for all the work the
wonderful work they've done over the
last three months I'm going out now to
campaign across the whole country for
those values and for that program I hope
very much that you will support us let's
get brexit done and unleash the
potential of the whole United Kingdom
thank you very much can they trust you
mr. Johnson